when i introduced you to the unit step
function i said you know this this type
of a function it's more exotic and a
little unusual relative to what you've
seen in just a traditional calculus
course what you've seen in in maybe your
algebra courses but the reason why this
was introduced because a lot of physical
systems
kind of behave this way that all of a
sudden nothing happens nothing happens
for a long period of time then bam
something happens and you go like that
and it doesn't happen exactly like this
but it can be approximated by the unit
step function similarly sometimes you
have nothing happening
you have nothing happening for a long
period of time nothing happens for a
long period of time and then whack
something hits you really hard and then
goes away and then you nothing happens
for a very long period of time and
you'll learn this in the future you can
kind of view this as an impulse and
we'll talk about unit impulse functions
and all of that so wouldn't it be neat
if we had some type of function that
could uh model this type of behavior and
and our ideal function what would happen
is is that nothing happens
nothing happens until we get to some
point and then bam it would get
infinitely strong but maybe it has a
finite area and then it would go back to
zero and then go like that so it'd be
infinitely
so high right at let's say zero right
there and then it goes continues and
let's say that the area under this i
mean it becomes very
to call this a function is actually kind
of pushing it and well this is beyond
the map of this video but we'll call it
a function in this video but what we can
you know you say well how do you even
you know what what good is this function
for how can you even manipulate it and
i'm going to make one more definition of
this function so what i just do here
let's say we call this function we
represented by the delta
and that's what we do represent this
function by it's called the dirac delta
function
and we'll just informally say look when
it's in infinity it pops up to infinity
when x
is equal to 0 and it's zero everywhere
else when x is not equal to zero
and so how do i deal with that how do i
take the integral of that and to help
you with that i'm going to make a
definition i'm gonna tell you what the
integral of this is this is part of the
definition of the function i'm gonna
tell you that if i were to take the
integral of this function from minus
infinity to infinity so essentially over
the entire a real number line
if i take the integral of this function
i'm defining it
i'm defining it to be equal to one
i'm defining this now you might say how
you didn't prove it to me no i'm
defining it i'm telling you that delta
this delta of x is a function such that
its integral is one so it has this
infinitely
narrow base that goes infinitely high
and and the area under this i'm telling
you is of area one and you're like hey
sal that's a crazy that's a crazy
function i want a little bit a little
bit better understanding of how someone
can construct a function like this so
let's let's see if we can if we can
satisfy that a little bit more but then
once that's satisfied then we're going
to start taking the laplace transform of
this and and then we'll start
manipulating it and whatnot let's see
let me put complete this delta right
here let's say that i constructed
another function let's call it
d
d sub tau
and this is all just to satisfy this
craving for maybe a better intuition for
how this dirac delta function can be
constructed and let's say my d sub tau
of well let me just put in in it's a
function of t because i want to when
everything we're doing in laplace
transform world everything's been a
function of t
so let's say that it equals
let's say that it equals
1 over 2 tau and you'll see why i'm
picking these numbers the way i am
1 over 2 tau
when t is less than tau
and greater than minus tau
and let's say it's 0 everywhere else
every
where else
so this type of this equation this is
more reasonable this will actually look
like a combination of unit step
functions and we can actually define it
as a combination of unit step functions
so if i draw
that's my x-axis
that's my x-axis and then if i put
my y-axis right here
that's my y-axis
y and this is sorry this is the t-axis
to get out of that habit this is the
t-axis and i mean we could call what we
call it the y-axis or the f of t-axis or
whatever we want to call it that's the
dependent variable so what's going to
happen here it's going to be 0
everywhere until we get to minus t and
then at minus t we're going to jump up
to some level
so let me put that point here so this is
minus tau
and this is plus
tau
right minus tau and plus tau so it's
going to be zero everywhere and then at
minus tau we jump to this level and then
we stay constant at that level
until we get to plus tau
and that level i'm saying is 1 over 2
tau
so this point right here
on the dependent axis this is 1 over 2
tau so why did i construct this function
this way
well let's think about it what happens
if i take
the integral
let me write a nicer integral sign if i
took the integral from minus infinity
to infinity
of
d
sub tau
of t
dt
what is this going to be equal to
well if you just i mean if the integral
is just the area under this curve this
is a pretty straightforward thing to
calculate right you just look at this
and you say well this is first of all
it's 0 everywhere else it's 0 everywhere
else and it's only the area
right here i mean i could write this i
could rewrite this integral as
the integral from minus tau
to tau we don't care infinity and minus
infinity and positive because there's no
area under any of those points of
1 over 2
tau
d tau we could write it
we could dt sorry 1 over 2 tau dt so we
could write it this way too right
because if we can just take the
boundaries from here to here because we
get nothing the whole other
whether t goes to positive infinity or
minus infinity and then over that
boundary the function is a constant 1
over 2 tau so we could just take this
integral and either way we evaluate it
we don't even have to know calculus to
know what this integral is going to
evaluate to this is just the area under
this
the area under this which is just the
base
what's the base the base is
2 tau
right the base is 2 tau you have one tau
here and then another tau there so it's
equal to two tau
times your height
and your height i just said is one over
two tau one over two tau
so your area for this function
or for this integral is going to be one
you could evaluate this you could get
this is going to be equal to you take
the anti-derivative of one over two tau
you get
i'll do this just to satiate your
curiosity t over two tau and you have to
evaluate this from from minus tau to tau
you put tau in there you get tau over
two tau
and then minus
minus tau
over two tau
and then you get tau plus tau over two
tau that's two tau
over two tau which is equal to one maybe
i'm i'm beating a dead horse i think
you're you're satisfied that the area
under this is going to be one regardless
of what tau was i kept this abstract
now if i take smaller and smaller values
of tau what's going to happen if my new
tau is
my new tau is going to be
let's say here let's say my new tau is
going to be there
i'm just going to pick my new tau there
then my 1 over 2 tau
tau is now a smaller number so when it's
in the denominator my 1 over 2 tau is
going to be something like this
it's going to be something like this
right i mean i'm just saying if i pick
smaller and smaller towels and if i pick
an even smaller towel than that
then my height is going to be have to be
higher right my 1 over 2 tau is going to
have to even be higher than that
and so i think you see where i'm going
this what happens is the limit as tau
approaches zero
so what is
the limit
as tau approaches
of my little d sub tau
function
what's the limit of this
well you're going to these things are
going to go infinitely close to zero but
this is the limit they're never going to
be quite at zero and your height here is
going to go infinitely high but the
whole time i said no matter what my tau
is because it was defined very awkward
for terms my area is always going to be
1. so you end up you're going to end up
you're going to end up with your dirac
delta function oh let me write it i was
going to write an x again your dirac
delta function is a function of t
and because of this
if you say
you know if you ask well you know what's
the limit
as tau approaches zero of the integral
from minus infinity to infinity of d sub
tau
of t dt well this should still be one
right because this thing right here this
evaluates to one so as you take the
limit as tau approaches zero and i'm
being very generous with my definitions
of limits and whatnot i'm not being very
rigorous but i think you can kind of
understand the intuition where i'm going
this is going to be equal to one and so
by the same i guess
intuitive argument
you could say that the limit as from
minus infinity to infinity of our dirac
delta function of t
dt
is also
going to be 1.
and likewise dirac delta function i mean
this thing
this thing pops up to infinity at at t
is equal to zero right this thing if i
were to draw my
x-axis
my x-axis like that and then right at t
equals a zero my dirac delta function
pops up like that and you normally draw
it like that and you normally draw it so
it goes up to 1 to kind of depict its
area but you actually put an arrow there
and so this is your delta function but
what happens if you want to shift it
what would how would i represent how
would i represent
my let's say i want to do t minus three
what would the graph of this be
well this would just be shifting it to
the right by three for example when t
equals three this will become the dirac
delta of 0. so this graph
this graph will just look like this
this will be my x-axis
let's say that this is my y-axis
let me just make that 1. and let me just
draw some points here so it's 1 2 3.
that's t is equal to 3. did i say that
was the x-axis my t-axis so this is t
equal to 3. and what i'm going to do
here is the dirac delta function is
going to be 0 everywhere
everywhere
0 everywhere but then right at 3 goes
infinitely high and obviously we don't
have enough paper to draw an infinitely
high spike right there so what we do is
we draw an arrow
we draw an arrow there and the arrow we
usually draw the magnitude of the area
under that spike
so we do it like this and let me be
clear this is not telling me that the
function just goes to 1 and then spikes
back down this tells me that the area
under the function is equal to one this
spike would have to be infinitely high
to have any area considering it has no
an infinitely uh small base so the the
area
the area under this
impulse function or under this dirac
delta function
now this one right here is
t minus three
but your area under this is still going
to be one and that's why i made the
arrow go to one if i had if i were to if
i let's say i wanted to graph let me do
it another color let's say i wanted to
graph 2 times
2 times
the dirac delta of t
minus 2. how would i graph this
well i would go to t minus 2
when t is equal to two you get the dirac
delta of zero so that's where you'd have
your spike and we're multiplying it by
two
so you would do it a spike twice as high
like this now both of these go to
infinity but this goes twice as high to
infinity well i know this is all being a
little ridiculous now but the idea here
is that the area under this curve should
be twice the area under this curve and
that's why we make the arrow go to two
to say that the area under this arrow is
two the spike would have to go
infinitely high so this is all a little
abstract but this is a useful way to
model things that are kind of very
jarring that you know all of a sudden
obviously nothing actually behaves like
this but there are a lot of phenomena in
in in i guess physics or the real world
that kind of you know have this spiky
behavior that you know and it's instead
of trying to say oh what does that spike
exactly look like we say hey that's a
dirac delta function and we'll dictate
its impulse by something like this
and just to give you a little bit of
motivation behind this and i was going
to go this i was going to go here in the
last video but then i kind of decided
not to
but i'm just going to show it because
i've been doing a lot of differential
equations i've been giving you no
motivation for how this applies in the
real world
but you can imagine if i have just a say
a wall and then i have a spring
attached to some mass
some mass
right there and let's say that this is
the natural state of the spring so the
spring would want to be here so it's
been stretched a distance y
from its kind of natural where it wants
to go
and let's say i have some external force
external force right here
let's say i have some external force
right here on the spring and and of
course let's say it's ice on ice there's
no friction in all of this and i just
want to show you that i can represent
this behavior of this system with a
differential equation and actually
things like the unit step function and
the dirac delta function actually start
to
become useful in this type of an
environment so we know that
we know that f is equal to mass times
acceleration
that's the basic physics right there now
what are all of the
forces on this on this on this on this
mass right here well you have
this you have this force right here
and we'll say this in the positive
rightward direction so it's that force
then you have a minus force from the
spring right the force from the spring
is hooke's law it's it's proportional to
how far it's been just stretched from
its kind of natural point so its force
in that direction is going to be ky or
you could call it minus ky because it's
going in the opposite direction of what
we've already said as a positive
direction so the net forces on this is f
minus
k y and that's equal to the mass of r
it's equal to the mass of r of our
object times its acceleration now what's
its acceleration if its position is y
so if y is equal to position
if we take the derivative of y with
respect to t
y prime which we could also say d y dydt
this is it's going to be its velocity
and then if we take the derivative of
that y prime prime which is equal to
d squared y with respect to dt squared
this is equal to acceleration
acceleration
so we can instead of writing a
we could write y prime prime
y prime prime and so if we just put this
on the other side of the equation what
do we get
we get the force this force not just
this force this is just f equals ma but
this force
is equal to the mass of our object times
the acceleration of the object
plus
whatever the spring constant is for this
spring plus k
times our position times y
so if you had no outside force if this
was zero you'd be have you'd have a
homogeneous differential equation and in
that case you know the spring would just
start moving on its own but now this f
all of a sudden the kind of the
non-homogeneous term it's it's what the
outside force you're applying to this to
this mass so if this outside force was
some type of dirac delta function so
let's say it's let's say it's t minus 2
is equal to you know our mass times y
prime prime
plus our spring
our spring constant times y this is
saying that at time is equal to two
seconds or we're just going to jar this
thing to the right and it's going to
have an and i'll talk more about it it's
going to have an impulse of two its
force times time is going to be or not
its impulse is going to have a one so
it's it's and i don't want to get too
much into the physics here but it's
impulse or its change in momentum is
going to be of magnitude 1 depending on
what our our units are but anyway i just
wanted to take that slight diversion
because you know you might be saying sal
is introducing me to these weird exotic
functions what are they ever going to be
good for
but this is good for the idea of at some
time you just you just jar this thing by
some magnitude and then let go and and
you do it kind of infinitely fast but
you do it with some
enough to to change the momentum of this
in a in a well-defined way anyway in the
next video we'll continue with the dirac
delta function we'll figure out its
laplace transform and see what it does
to the laplace transforms of other
functions